copenhague ville tranquille en bord de
mer ou la bicyclette et rennes
le civisme le respect de l'ordre saint
paul la capitale du royaume nordique qui
se transforme avec l'arrivée d'étrangers
la vague de réfugiés qui a déferlé sur
l'europe il ya quelques années s'est
rendu jusqu'à ce petit pays
le raz-de-marée si trop de gens viennent
trop rapidement sa cause des problèmes
face aux nouveaux arrivants les danois
craignent pour leur identité et la
cohésion que leur société
on ne reconnaît plus le danemark mais
les lois sont pensés pour que ça
redevienne le danemark on connaît à
guern
une réaction qui rappelle les propos du
président américain en réponse la
coalition de droite au pouvoir employer
la méthode du l'aide aux arrivants est
dorénavant moins généreuse et moins
rapide le danemark veut que les migrants
contribuent davantage à leur
installation
et pour ceux qui sont déjà sur place
toute une série de contraintes pour
briser les enclaves est né par exemple
l'aide sociale sera moins généreuse pour
ceux qui emménage dans ces quartiers les
bambins devront fréquenter des garderies
à l'extérieur des zones ciblées
nous parlons de société qui vivent en
parallèle des ondes que le gouvernement
danois ne contrôle plus tout à fait la
loi ou le foie respecter l'un policiers
ne peuvent pas y entrer librement nos
ambulances ne peuvent y aller sans
escorte policière
tous se plaint un mot a suscité la
controverse et attiré beaucoup
d'attention le mot ghetto pour désigner
des endroits comme ici souvent des
petits regroupements d'édifices dans
lesquelles le gouvernement juge qu'il y
a trop de crimes
trop de pauvreté est trop de gens issus
de l'immigration
ici ce n'est pas un ghetto sur les
résidents de milner parquet quartiers au
centre de copenhague
souvent montrés du doigt par les
autorités il n'y a pas plus de problème
ici qu'ailleurs sur yann limited qui
nous fait visiter ce complexe de
logements abordables surtout habité par
des immigrants un petit quartier bien
ordinaire
que sa garderie son parc les seules
traces de criminalité sont ces graffitis
recouvert qui rappelle les rivalités
entre deux gains les rivalités que le
gouvernement utilise pour justifier sa
main de fer pour les crimes commis si la
peine est deux fois plus sévère que si
vous voulez comme ici de l'autre côté de
la rue ce ne sont que des punitions
tempête mohamed aslam qui acceptent de
parler au nom des résidents de mineurs
parc
ici les offres d'emploi centre danois
comme l'entrevue qui nous accordent les
partis de droite ont peur de perdre des
appuis et il pense à la prochaine
élection
ils luttent pour être perçus comme les
plus strictes possibles sur les
questions d'immigration
l'intégration des étrangers
cette association où il travaille
justement dans une odyssée enclave
ethnique identifié par le gouvernement
les familles viennent volontairement
pour apprendre les moeurs danoise comme
laisser un bébé dormir à l'extérieur en
plein hiver c'était un peu bizarre la
première fois ils m'ont expliqué qu'il y
avait une alarme qu'on pouvait
surveiller le bébé c'était difficile au
début mais avec le temps j'ai appris à
leur faire confiance
cette jeune mère combien se plier aux
nouvelles contraintes
les règles sont les règles il faut les
suivre
si tu ne veux pas les suivre mieux vaut
aller dans un autre pays où tu pourras
faire les règles
la responsable des lieux n'est pas
d'accord il croit que le danemark est
trop sévère envers les nouveaux
arrivants bien sûr c'est une bonne chose
de brisé ces sociétés parallèles mais ça
ne marchera pas en forçant les gens en
leur enlevant des droits ils sont en
train de transformer notre démocratie
en quelque chose d'autre une critique
qui s'adresse directement
partis de gauche et aux députés que
celui ci lui même fils de réfugiés
migration est un défi pour la cohésion
sociale et la solidarité au sein de la
population
membre du principal parti d'opposition
il appuie mesures sévères contre les
étrangers pourraient des danois moins
fortunés qui a payé le plus pour
l'arrivée de tous ces migrants
ceux qui ont peu d'argent et peu
d'éducation
leurs enfants vont dans des écoles à
problème il ya des créneaux leur
quartier le fardeau repose sur leurs
épaules le fardeau que son parti veut
redistribuer plus équitablement en
fermant la porte
beaucoup de migrants c'est la réponse de
pays à une crise qui frappe toute
l'europe